teame
日本で好きなものはとよく聞かれる相手が同年代の男性なるいつもリオと答えているか
そうでない場合は敗者と言っている僕は日本の歯医者が大好きだ
それは20年間アメリカの歯医者に通っていたからかもしれない
padi
ani
品川の新築マンションのリビングみたいな清潔で黒千代や電球が見えないように天井の
端が二重になっている
どこからともなく小川な音がしている乳白色の革製ソファ
暗めのフローリングファブリーズのハワイアンフラワーの香り入口の反対側の壁には
60インチをあるかと思われるし
ソニーの bravia がかかっていて世界のパワースポット的な番組が流れている
ギザの黄色いピラミートとジュリマリの yuki さんに似た可愛い女の子のガイド
が映っている映像が綺麗で画質の良いテレビというよりむしろ窓越しにエジプトの砂漠
を見ているという感覚だ
yuki さんがピラミッドの超
頭を指さして微笑む高さを460m だ
部屋の中央には黒江つや消しの低いコーヒーテーブルがありその上には青い花を3本さ
せたガラスの花瓶が置いてあるつまりには何かドイツばらしい言葉の刻まれた海みたい
な小さな白い彫刻家の隅では羽根のない扇風機が言う
いうとかを振りながら涼しさをかき回して他の感じはみんな窓の向こうのピラミッドを
静かに眺めたい
ファッション雑誌のページをパラパラめくったりしている目を閉じたら無意識のうちに
蓮華座を組んで座禅を始めてしまいそうなぐらい
平穏な環境だ分
かま定期まで当方20分の昭和35年築の
コンクリート造りのはパートナー
地下にあっ
某エラー室そんな雰囲気を醸し出す窓もなければエアコンもない
今にもゴキブリや音がぞろぞろ出てきそうな窮屈で蒸し暑い部屋
アンモニアと漂白剤の匂いイストのフットレストもつかない何か大きくて丸くて黒い物
空港の通路にあるような渦巻き模様がずっと連なったか
パペット素材が余ったのかそれとも壁紙が足りなかったのか
壁も同じカーペットで追われているところどころなちゅチーズのように見えるシミが
ついている近所の映画館か捨てた母てとなんだろうか
天井にはコンビニや銀行の警備モニター思い出させる小さなテレビがかかっていて
灰色の棒グラフが2つ
写っている画質は現防衛カラーと銀ボーイアドバンスの中間でスピーカーからを
モールス信号と32キロバイトのポッドキャストが混ざり合ったような雑音が流れて
いる部屋の中央には金魚の水槽が子どもたちが見て楽しめるように置いたんだろうが
ガラスは指紋だらけで金魚たちは深緑色の人口ミニ35
フォション後ろに集まっている
騒がしいアメリカの子供たちのおかげで金魚はうんざりという気持ちを知っている
モールス信号と一緒にドリルの甲高い音と子どもたちの叫び声が聞こえる
5秒以上目を閉じていると
シリアの拷問施設にいるように思えてくる
バッハ ni